dear Miss Kelsey we regret to inform you
that you have not been submitted for
works to do a GP
Hogwarts is nothing like the books sure
you have your houses your athletic jocks
in Gryffindor your jaded one of these
slytherins your hips and nerds in raven
core and you're happy hufflepuffs but
that's about where the similarities end
what are you doing in there just
studying some herbology dude there's a
recreation of spells with no goddamn
room
the Gryffindor's hated losing almost as
much as the slytherins loved cheating
wait a minute
you took a Felix blesseth oh it wasn't a
Hogwarts party without an old-fashioned
duel
and suck the soul out of a party in
seconds
so there you have it Hogwarts isn't what
you expected but at least it's full of
the brightest students around well whoa
wait wait where you going well I'm fine
home grooming home you can't fly home I
saw you shocker like five butter beers
man I I'm on why you what you like
Dumbledore I'm fight him know this hey
I'm gonna stay
no no no Oh will will get up man come on
Barry she's good this is come on wake up